I also didn't check like my camera
battery so
put the other one I just hope I have a
battery like
charging already so I'm not too worried
about it
yeah I like using my Sony but the
battery never makes it through like
battery lasts like 30 minutes
mine lasts a long time because it's
plugged in right oh my gosh I Got a
notification I wonder who it's from
bring it down
okay
cool Daniel Allen Barnes what's up
Predator gaming yo what's going on oh
Cosmic culture
wow wow indeed hello Mark The Stranger
Anthony oh Anthony sauce what's up man
Ethan shadowmaster
what's up Bucky what's going on Joe
Silas Shadow master I think Ethan
yeah so uh we'll wait till a little bit
more people get in the chat but Chris
did you hear
and then everybody here that the um
the intro
like the opening credits for secret
invasion was done by AI
yeah I actually didn't hear that until
after I'd already made the sweeping
declaration that I hated the intro so
that makes me happy
I'm anti-aii so the fact that I
naturally hated something that AI made
I'm okay with that yeah I like didn't
even like to be truthfully honest I
didn't even
I didn't really look through it because
I was just like what is this and I was
like you know what I actually don't care
it's like two minutes long so after like
45 seconds I'm like skip like I don't
even care like yeah I know that was one
of my the first comments I made about
secret Invasion like I love secret
Invasion hated the intro yeah the the
it was interesting and what's funny is
like I actually remember saying when I
watched it when I got the screener for
the first time I was like this looks
like it was like made by AI because I've
seen like I've done a few sponsors for
AI and like I'll try to do it and like
they work most the time if you if you
get like the premium ones but if you do
like the free ones they like always
screw it up a little bit and there was
like the picture of Nick Fury and he's
like half scroll
but like barely half scroll and I'm like
that looks like it's like an AI messed
up doing it and then they come out and
they're like yeah they used it
they used AI for it I'm like ah and I
know that was very obvious yeah and I
know a lot of people talk about like um
like who cares and it doesn't have
anything to do with like quality or
anything like that it has to do with
like the whole VFX people
already
complaining right but like at the same
time too much to do right they have too
much to do so at the same time it's kind
of like well Marvel Studios use the AI
to do it but then you know the VFX
people were like well we would have
rather gotten paid to do that and uh
that's some that's stuff that we really
don't dive into too much you know we try
to
we try to just keep it on like the
content and things that like affect yeah
the stuff right yeah yeah but what it
like go ahead in the chat right away
what did everybody think
um
of the first episode
what are our thoughts did everybody like
it I have like so much going on so if
you all see me like looking everywhere
I've got a bunch of screens I'm doing
the same thing your screens here a
laptop down yeah my phone's over here
I've got the chat like down here
uh
this is a spoiler talk did I put that in
like the thumbnail or the title let me
see I think you put in the title didn't
you spoiler secret Invasion spoil attack
so if you are here you've been warned
we're just gonna go ahead I'm gonna give
you like five seconds and we're and
we're gonna talk about spoilers
three four
five Maria Hill is she dead or not we're
just gonna go into it you think she's
really dead really yes yes I
I I
it's so weird because you're in a show
where it's and I mentioned this in my my
breakdown you're like she's literal like
somebody has literally been disguised as
her before like a scroll has literally
been here yeah but she didn't turn to a
scroll so but that's the thing and I've
seen episode two
right yeah right so we won't spoil that
um
but yeah
it's so hard to say because like this is
uh like kind of like a mystery show
where you never know but I do think
she's dead and I think it was done for a
very specific reason I think
that's how you like set the sticks like
this guy means business graphic means
business he blew up
that town square and he kills I think
they say in like the next episode he
killed like 2 000 people something like
that like it's like in the thousands
it's in the thousands yeah no that's I
don't yeah right so it's like neither
confirm or deny yeah well they say that
and then they say
well they say that and then and then he
kills Moon Maria Hill so
but uh well I think one of the biggest
not one of the biggest but definitely a
high up their complaint for Marvel
over the years has been like oh there's
never Stakes somebody dies and they come
back right exactly they they tease
deaths and nobody dies like even with as
emotionals Guardians of the Galaxy was
like nobody died so like I feel like
they're giving us what we want and
everybody's like no she can't be dead
yeah she can definitely be dead
especially if like
if they're trying like I keep asking
myself
is
is this the end of Fury as well does he
die at the end of this right and I've
only we've only seen two episodes so I
have no idea how it ends but I keep
asking myself
this does feel like like the end of an
era a little bit especially if we're
going in like if phase seven is going to
be all about the mutants and the
Fantastic Four are are they going are
they kind of like moving away from the
past which is the original Avengers
and then getting rid of Fury and Hill
and like
you know how does how does it end does
it end with Fury dying or retiring
because somebody else is coming in
like fear it's not going to be Fury
handling the Avengers and the X-Men and
the Fantastic Four the new superhero
team that's that's not what it's going
to be right so
and maybe it's Taylor no maybe Taylor's
is the one who steps in and does it but
maybe Peter Parker is the only steps and
does it when he grows up
I think we're trying to get you know
some real Stakes some real consequences
Fury is obviously made just from what's
been hinted even in the first episode
a lot of mistakes and let a lot of
people down and now he has to live with
the consequence so right right man
that's on him right and he needs to feel
that pain just to become whatever it is
he needs to become or to finish his
story whether that's he dies or tires or
whatever but I do think we're phasing
out of it like he's done exactly his
time exactly and that and but that's why
I do believe that Maria Hill is man I'm
really like on the fence about it I
think I'm leaning a little bit more
towards Hill is dead
um but even I mentioned in my breakdown
right yeah but but I mean you know
Coulson died in Avengers and got brought
back right so
I think they killed her but if they ever
needed to bring her back they could
um well that's always the case right
well and that's like the classic comic
like Kamala Khan Miss Marvel died in the
comics recently and they've already said
they're like oh yeah she's coming back
they're literally this was something
cool Side Story for a second we've we've
always seen the comics affect the movies
but this is the first time like a show
Miss Marvel has affected the comics
because she's a mutant in the MCU and
now they killed her in the comics
because she's a uh and human and now
they are bringing her back as
an actual mutant
which is interesting we've never seen
the MCO actually affect Comics like that
before be retcon but anyways people come
back all the time
but I do think they're moving away and
like you said whether Fury dies or
whether he just kind of retires or does
whatever I think they are moving away
and jumping into a new MCU with fresh
new characters
um
I think we're going to see a lot of that
in Phase five and phase six and then
especially in Phase seven so I I think
they wanted to kill her to to one start
to move on from these characters and I'm
sure she's okay moving on as well
because she's done it forever now since
the first Avengers film and then two to
show that the stakes are really high
like like this is a villain who doesn't
care he'll he'll kill them uh I see a
lot of people asking me
which is better Proxima century and a
few other people I saw it which is
better episode one or two
um
kind of merged together in my head to be
honest
when you're watching back to back
I think there's more action in the first
one
I I don't expect this show to be very
action-packed though like it's an
Espionage Thriller to me right I like
the mystery right I like the whole a lot
of mystery in this I like the searching
of the evidence right for evidence and
stuff like that like I really like it
I'm not expecting too much action but
there's a lot of backstory given in the
second one
um I'm trying to remember it really
I know it's that's why I was like they
kind of merged together yeah I watched
like two weeks ago
we were watching it last night and I'm
like I don't I didn't say it like I
don't remember if Marie actually dies in
this one or the second one like I
couldn't remember yeah
but uh no the second one has a lot of
like
what just happened moments I think yeah
um I see some people saying in the chat
you haven't watched it yet guys spoiler
talk it's in the title this is a spoiler
talk
um yeah sorry
um if we're spoiling somebody on um my
side brought up a good point that I
think we'll definitely get to so
wasn't Fury in the Marvel's trailer
yes
oh yeah
what does that mean you know was that
before was it after well I I think it
could very well be before
um it does have like eye patch and
there's no beard
does he have an eye patch in it I don't
remember eye patch no beard in the he
looks like he normally does in the
Marvel's trailer maybe it's a scroll I
don't know if that's like after secret
Invasion and he goes back to being
normal Nick Fury maybe a scroll takes
next round that's not a bad point either
um
maybe I mean there is definitely the
possibility that he could finish out the
Saga
right but I I do think in the next Saga
we move away from the some of the OG
characters like Nick Fury I don't think
we move away from like the Avengers of
the whole to be completely well that's
what I'm saying I think it come it
becomes all about the X-Men and uh the
Fantastic Four and then the rebuilding
of the Avengers team eventually like
view like in next phase after that or
something a few faces later yeah uh next
song after that many phases later but
the next Saga
um I
you know it says present day
when the episode starts and during the
press conference
it was kind of like alluded at but
basically it is it is now it takes place
in time but they kind of also alluded
that
um like the order of the release is the
order that they're in so yeah maybe the
Marvels is right after all these events
happen and maybe this kicks Fury into
gear and is like I'm back baby like
it's also just as possible that the
beginning of the Marvels was
four years before just like this one
started that's what I was gonna say
thank you yeah like it's very possible
that
you know there's time jumps
because there's still a lot that I think
Fury that I would assume Fury needs to
explain about what's going on with
you know saber or sword or whatever
they've ended up calling it now and
like that would be like what's he been
doing up there the whole time or has he
only been hiding has he actually been
doing something that needs to be
explained because I feel like that would
fall to him to explain right exactly
well and you know Roadie and the
president who's our guy
did you notice that the president's
played by uh yeah yeah yeah
absolutely that's the move
um they you know he's building like the
most uh Advanced uh I don't remember the
actual phrase that he said but the most
advanced complicated aerodynamic weapon
defense system like ever and um let's
talk about like Roadie like
this needs to be discussed I think he's
I I think he might be a scroll because
he's like I think he has to be and no
spoilers but even more in episode two I
feel I'm like you're a scroll but like
when I watched this I was like what I'm
like bro you just ratted out Nick Fury
like you know how long you fought beside
Nick Fury to just rat him out like that
I think
it's kind of like okay let's play how do
you detect a scroll like what does a
scroll have to gain from a certain
character doing this action like not to
mention your point like these are blood
brothers
and back and the first thing he's gonna
do before he even like calls or tries to
contact mcfury like what would the
character actually do he would try to
contact Nick Fury he'd find a way he'd
get a suit on he'd fly out he goes right
he would go try right and see him first
thing Roadie is doing is not running to
the president and tattletailing that
that's and that's what that's how I saw
it that's how I saw it I was like the
dude's literally like a tattletale he's
like ratting them out I'm like what are
you trying to get brownie points for the
president man like you're already up
there yeah right yeah there's no way
yeah it's I'm just sitting there like
either that or
like I don't know I just can't see it to
where it's like like especially after
everything they've been to been through
Roadies just sitting there like
oh yeah I'm gonna be this big political
guy and I I'm Mr you know America now
and I'm gonna you know I stick to the
rule book no matter what you know it's
like
and then I would just say part two of
that same how do you detect the Scrolls
like what do they have to gain from this
character doing something out of their
character like oh let's get Nick Fury
Maria Hill on the on the most wanted
list and make them not have American
resources and like there's everything
for this girl to gain from that so not
only is this out of his character but
scroll are getting big points from this
happening right almost too obvious no
and and that's the only reason why I
question like well is he because it is
pretty obvious
I mean the scroll do have a lot to gain
and the whole premise of the monologue
in the beginning by agent Prescott was
like he specifically says like what if
the people you thought you could trust
the people closest to you the ones you
loved you couldn't trust what if they
were actually not from this world or if
they were aliens and it's just kind of
like that is setting it up that's
actually a part I love about the show is
that you really don't know right we
think roady's a scroll but do we know no
no but you know maybe after Civil War
I mean probably if he's if he's so are
they too if rhodo is a scroll then I I
would have I would imagine that they
would take out the president and put
their own
in that spot so they can do what they
want
there is an interesting point here
though and I think Amelia Clarke's
character explained this in the first
one
like they don't even all know
like it's possible I think I don't
really know how it works but they could
both be scrolling be so good at being
human that neither of them know right
neither of them know yeah and they do
mention that in this episode yeah
they're like you have to stick to your
shell like you you can't go in your
scroll form don't change forms stick to
your specific shell that way it's a lot
harder for for humans to track but in
that
instance it's also harder for the scroll
to track as well especially if you're
not very well connected yeah yeah so
that's also a possibility I feel like
maybe everybody would know if the
president was a scroll like the Scrolls
would maybe know that one but there are
specific roles where it's like
yeah right
yeah and
I think we're gonna see
I think that's the big thread of the
scroll I think that's the secret
Invasion threat I think we're gonna see
a lot of people in power gonna be scroll
and I'm actually thinking like
what if an Avenger does come in and what
if they're a scroll right like I think
that's that would make a pretty
interesting story like I don't want them
to negate anything that's happened right
like I don't want like anybody from
Avengers endgame who like fought in the
battle anyone important at least to be a
scroll right like maybe maybe you can
like I know there was as Guardians right
so maybe it's like oh like one of the
last Guardians was actually a scroll or
something like that right one of the
wakandans will scroll or something like
that but like Thor being a scroll like
don't do that like like we can't yeah
that would be a slap in the face like we
can't have Thor be a scroll but I would
like for one of them to show up and
maybe be like I heard you needed help
and then it's like
well how did you hear I needed help
nobody
nobody I didn't reach out to you nobody
reached out to you and then it's like oh
that's a scroll and then yeah right
exactly so like we see Nick Fury like
shoot Thor or something like that right
but of course it's you know really want
to be them
but there is that question what no go
ahead no you go ahead because I'm
irrelevant I was just gonna say but
there is a question and they established
this in the very beginning like Everett
Ross was a scroll
so where's the real one we think he's in
wakanda based off of wakanda forever but
was that the scroll like you know what I
mean like you've been captured and they
did the Mind sucking thing exactly we
have zero idea which is what I love
about the show actually yeah it's so
mysterious and I love it
that's like the biggest thing anymore
was a scroll right
so that's definitely going to raise a
lot of questions and it's going to give
them an opportunity to
in kind of a cheating way maybe change a
bit of the rules about what might have
happened in the past that they maybe
were cemented to and opened them up to
some freedoms moving forward for writing
yeah there definitely is a lot of
potential that could come out of this
like
it doesn't make it like Limitless but
like there is a lot of freedom now
yeah exactly actually Marvel right now
the MCU in general right now is in a
position to where they actually do have
a ton of Freedom with the Multiverse and
and scroll like you know like it's just
like okay spoilers again if you just
joined it's a spoiler talk so click away
like literally right now like click away
but like it that's why it makes like
like Maria Hill could have very well
been a scroll like she might not be dead
they can do anything they want if they
could actually retcon it too she could
come back in Captain Marvel and they're
gonna be like wait didn't she die I'm
like nah that was actually a scroll like
you know what I mean some people might
consider that kind of cheap
oh I would but I also I also don't like
like ah man
I it's really like I love Robin right
from How I Met Your Mother like I love
Kobe Smulders and I love
Maria Hill's character so I don't want
her to die but but like if she really is
dead if they did that I actually think
it's pretty brilliant like it's a great
how many times
how many times can we have the smoke and
mirrors effect though where it's like oh
they're dead oh no they're not oh
they're dead oh no they're not right
right it's a pretty common move with
marvel at this point so it's time to mix
it up you know what they're dead and
it's actually very common with like Nick
Fury because that's what happened in
winter solstice thing right but is it
Maria Hills thing
all right like is is she the one
that can do it too since she's like his
best bud but you know what you know what
Maria Hills Mephisto confirmed boom done
you heard it here first folks Maria Hill
is you're already here first
she's in the hell realm right now she's
gotta come back and the Iron Heart
series which also involves link with
Roadie and all the stuff there Marie
Hill's mefisto confirmed called it
nailed it right here
boom
um oh I was gonna say something though
I don't know what you're thinking
I just want to talk about the greatest
line from the first episode
oh wait hold on let me let me guess what
you're gonna say
give me a hint where is it at in the
episode
middle oh gosh
it's time cares about your shitty art
no but that was a good that was pretty
good right
before that you tell me what what did
you get for yours The Avengers there you
go yeah
I'm not even 40 in my uh I'm not even
40. I haven't even gone through my
middle age crisis years what did you get
for you what did you get
that's a great line right there that's
just that's just good right
that's probably a robot wrote it
[Laughter]
you know what I hear that Sam Jackson
didn't even act he's just AI you know
he's a girl I'm kidding by the way let's
not have that let's not have that get
out there
kidding obviously Sam I actually met Sam
Jackson I was waiting to interview uh
Kingsley benedir
uh wait can you hear me still
yeah okay my headset's like dying I just
plugged in I was waiting to
um interview King's Loop in a Dairy
plays uh graphic and Sam Jackson walked
down the hall I was like holy crap
that's Sam Jackson and uh I just kind of
got up and I was just like hey Sam big
fan really looking forward to this one
and he was like oh hey man thanks man
he's like am I I'll talk to you in just
a bit and I was like oh no I won't be
interviewing you today but hey have a
good day I was like what can I slide in
can I can you make that happen
and then uh Amelia Clark came down the
hallway actually so
um Ben Mendelson came first Taylor's and
I was just I didn't really say anything
to him because he was talking so I
wasn't about to like interrupt him and I
have to be professional of course and
like Disney employees and Marvel
employees like everywhere around so I
was just kind of like gave him a smile a
little nod then Sam Jackson came he
wasn't really talking so I just said Hi
and then Emilia Clarke came I basically
said the same thing hey big fan really
excited to see this to you know see you
in this one she's like oh thank you so
much she kept walking that was pretty
much it and then uh I did the director
interview and graphic interview
everybody's just super nice when they do
that but um
Sam Jackson is he's like as he walks
down the hall he's just you're just like
that's Sam Jackson he's got so much
Swagger it's crazy just being him like
it's crazy just the way he talks and
everything and uh I love how he got some
of that in this show
like I don't remember the word and I
guess I I probably shouldn't say the
word
but he's like uh uh Maria Hill's like
you can't say that he's like you can't
say that I don't remember the word but
um I do
well we'll we'll hold off yeah
um but that's like such a it's just that
just feels like Sam Jackson talking you
know what I mean I think and I think I
have like few Sam Jackson and Nick fear
together in all honesty
I mean
it's one of those Robert Downey Jr right
exactly that's what has happened and
that's something that
I'm hoping as we're seeing Marvel take a
couple steps backwards and rebuild and
re-appreciate everything like that's
what we're really missing is name a
character from the original Infinity
Saga that hadn't become
the actor or vice versa we're not I
don't feel like we're getting that quite
as much and that's a big part of it is
that emotional connection yeah I don't
think so I don't think with a lot of the
new characters like no more is great
right or you know pick a character but
I'm not sitting there like wow this is
that person personified in real life
yeah I'm trying really Chris Hemsworth
yes Chris Evans yes Robert Downey Jr yes
uh Scarlett Johansson yes Nick Fury like
they have become the personification of
this character in the real world and I
don't feel like we've gotten that in
this phase just yet you know we're still
early days and I appreciate that but
where is that do you think of the real
world and the MCU that just makes it
that much more real
hmm maybe I don't know if she counts
Elizabeth Olsen because she's kind of
from I mean since Age of Ultron so she's
kind of an OG yeah I'd say the closest
I'd say the closest we've honestly
gotten is with um
Iman
oh yeah who's amazing yeah but she still
has only had a little Disney Plus show
so I think in the Marvels to be
completely honest she's gonna carry it
and I think she's gonna really step up
actually I think she's gonna step up and
become one of the faces of
New Marble
yeah I think
I I agree because I met her in person
I'm trying to think where I met her
Guardians of Galaxy 3 premiere it was
after I met her and she was like looking
at me and it was really funny so I just
like went up to her and she's like are
you warned I was like yeah so she
watches the channel she's a huge pop
culture fan
um so I know she watches me a real
rejects I know she watches new rock
stars
um and she is like the nicest person
ever and she literally is just like she
is Miss Marvel she really is and I
I liked her show I think the writing got
a little bit sloppy at the end but she
was great herself and I do agree I think
she's going to carry the Marvels I think
she's going to be yeah yeah probably the
the most likable part of it and I I like
Brie Larson you know I like Brie Larson
and I actually think somebody actually
that we've seen looks really good but
yeah no I get you're about to say it's a
testament towards Khan more than less of
them right it's more like this she's got
this and she's really and that's
something I I truthfully don't think
we've seen too too much like I like
Jonathan Majors as king but I don't look
at him and go wow that's Kang you know
he's a good Kang he plays The Good King
that's fantastic there's still something
oh I think he's great but I'm still I
don't know what it is
and I'll say it maybe it's the race
swapping that makes it hard for me to
like put that together maybe it's not I
don't I don't really know
um but I do feel like there's elements
that are missing for some of the casting
and now we're hearing about some of this
crazy fantastic forecasting and all
these other things it's just like I
don't know I really hope that they can
buckle down and get us some of that
original
Avengers world connections right yeah
not related to secret Invasion at all
but something I do believe the Chicken
Nugget Boy graphic does look awesome he
is really cool and uh obviously been a
deer is really cool it's really cool to
talk to him well and and I think it was
Grace Randolph who said this in a tweet
where she was like you know they're
casting these big name actors what
happened to Casting like not so known
actors and like Marvel Cinematic
Universe making their careers right it's
like and that's where we haven't had
that yet
with a new face since since uh end game
I like here hold on let's
I'm gonna I'm gonna go through
Marvel phase four here
let's take a look see so Marvel phase
four
foreign
I mean and it's different because like
okay Black Widow we already had black
widow Falcon in the Winter Soldier we
already had them there's still some
bleeding over right right uh seem a Leo
kind of a Shang chi I mostly think of
Kim's Convenience when I when I hear
semen well that's the problem right yeah
uh he was kind of known before it wasn't
huge uh one division Loki you know oh
Loki but he's an OG right like when I
see Tom pettel I think he's Loki right
old uh Doctor Strange old I make an
argument for Elizabeth Olsen but she's
still kind of an OG uh still a free end
game
and then you have
um Kate Bishop
she was pretty good but again I think
the impact of the Disney plus series you
don't really have the opportunity to see
that like you would in a movie and
that's the same with Miss Marvel when
she gets into her movie that's really
Gonna Shine and I think Kate Bishop is
one that's there that could shine if
they get her in the right role in the
right story but I don't really even see
where she fits that's that exciting I
mean Hawkeye was kind of like even that
but even that she's a singer an actress
like she was already oh she's she's
pretty famous yeah right exactly she was
pretty famous before so it's not like
she was Kate bishop and then her career
exploded right
so then throw love and thunder we got
Thor
um and then what if nothing there
eternally somebody in your chat said
Moon Knight I give that
well uh uh
yeah so I mean he was pretty famous
don't get me wrong
like the casting is good but there's
that element of I do cut that that would
probably I think that would be the
closest for phase four actually
that's a good one yeah other than Miss
Marvel which these those aren't listed
on here because this was like the first
revealed phase four uh before not what
actually no no this was like what they
revealed at first not what was actually
because they were you know they would
end up putting you know She-Hulk was you
know
um
yeah I'm not seeing you know anything I
mean even like Gore like I feel like the
fact that Gore was Christian Bale took
away from the character I loved it I
think he did a really good job
but I look at it and I see Christian
Bale smile
and yeah yeah yeah and it's you know and
you know I think
we have such the problem is is like
literally phase one through three did
make careers for people like Tom Holland
is Spider-Man you know what I mean like
yeah he's done Uncharted and he's done
all this other stuff too but that's
after but when you hear Tom Holland you
go Spider-Man oh Spiderman when you hear
Robert Downey Jr you go Iron Man
right when I hear Haley Steinfeld I'm
I'm like okay starving
Transformers right exactly and then oh
yeah Kate Bishop I feel like that's
almost an afterthought and that's like
a problem it's not a problem problem
well what I was going to say is I'm not
like knocking her as Kate Bishop I think
she's just done some excellent things
before
you brought too much baggage to the MCU
not baggage in a bad way just like
not baggage yeah because I actually do
think she makes a pretty dang perfect
Kate Bishop but but it isn't like I see
Haley Steinfeld just as Kate Bishop
Oscar Isaac is pretty close I would say
Oscar Isaac was president he's a really
good mood night and I loved Moon night I
just and I'm kind of piecing this
together while I'm talking about I
hadn't actually thought about this
previously it just kind of came up in
the conversation I'm like this is kind
of a little bit of a trend we're not
really making and now we got Adam Driver
Margot Robbie yeah Vanessa Kirby like
all of these
super famous people
like Mary I don't care how good Margot
Robbie does as
to storm
still nobody's gonna look at her go oh
yeah that's Sue storm like she's been so
many things in the last five years same
with Adam Driver he's been in tons of
movies he was kylo Ren that's the part
that's the problem with
it's when people have played iconic
roles like Adam Driver or kylo Ren
Margot Robbie not going away right and
that's going to be
an issue for some people when watching
if they if they are you know shoe
storeman Reed Richards that's going to
be the problem when people are watching
they're just going to go all I see is
Harley Quinn all I see is kylo Ren
and
but we'll ready Quinn yes change the
Fantastic Four names to Ren and Quinn
and Quinn
is my nephew's name
um and I call him
um
thank you Safi Safi sci-fi just
unrelated Food For Thought I think
that's it kind of just popped up in my
head who was the guy playing Neymar
again
Huerta
and I know I look white
color
and I know I'm white but I am fluent in
Spanish
see
okay
it's it's a what is it called when a
word has two meanings
uh double entender double entender sure
that's what we'll go with me and Chris
both
we're smart
would you say that gosh that's a great
movie
let's agreement yeah but all right
secret invasion
yeah
Furious
Samuel Jackson is Fury and he will be
missed that is yeah that is interesting
because
the Marvel's trailer I gotta look it up
I gotta look it up now no he's like
straight up look at he's walking without
a limp he's like skinnier he looks
younger
but it's definitely within the last five
years because it's post um
what the hell are you doing oh it's
coming on my speakers
oh yeah no he's got it yeah he looks
like
yeah he's got a real young
he almost looks like confusingly okay
like what is going on here
yeah so like here hold on let me
like even if this is before secret
Invasion like why does he look this good
right
like so it almost has to be after and he
got his crap together
bandor is a scroll
I feel like he's missing marks on top of
his eye here
which is interesting yeah better clean
shaved
yep
walking straight yeah
so I'm gonna say he gets his crap
together
some at some time I I think actually
spoilers guys
for you I gotta say spoilers again you
clicked on it
Deputy 1024 says I haven't seen the
episode yet there's no spoilers right oh
wild Deputy I don't see you in my chat
Iron Man Comes Back rude
um okay but spoilers guys like because
you know it's a spoiler chat
um
I think the death of Hill
is going to
bring out kind of the old Fury I think
he's gonna hire I think he's gonna sit
there and be remorseful for a bit and
maybe a little bit sorry for himself and
then maybe get a pep talk from Talos or
something like that and because if you
watch like as I was real I think I
watched it like four times because you
know my breakdown and stuff like that
and I watched it a couple times for my
interview to prep for that and um
I I noticed like at the end when they're
running through and he's like chasing
um
graphic he's not he doesn't move the
same like he's very timid right and he's
like afraid to take the shot what's the
uh it's like the Bond movie when he
comes back
and and uh they're like trying to get
him to pass the test and then he's like
The Yips right and he's like afraid to
shoot right and so the guy puts like
something on the girl's head and he was
like shoot it off her and he can't
right because he's like not the same
Bond I almost feel like it's that which
is great because they're both like spy
Thriller you know characters
um
but I think something's gonna happen and
and the and this death here is going to
kick him into to gear so he can be the
old Nick Fury
because she because I think like
what's gonna haunt him is
the talk that she had with him
right before where she's like
check your footing right you're you need
to go back like
you're not the same you're always three
steps ahead you haven't even decided yet
you're not ready for this I'm your
friend and I think that's gonna kind of
haunt him and bring it back out of him
yeah well just wait until graphic turns
into her
just to mess with his brain right right
exactly oh gosh it's obviously not point
oh that's awesome
yeah that's coming up soon right that's
gonna be yeah one of the big showdowns
and he's gonna be changing into her and
saying stuff and
it's gonna be terrible for Nick hey Jay
wait who died
you clicked on a spoiler discussion
you could get the Discord if you want to
are you off work are you home
so yeah
I don't know why but there's like one
comment that's pinned to the bottom
unless this person keeps yeah I don't
know how to I actually like did that the
other day too and I didn't know how to
stop it yeah
did you already discuss the scene
between agent Fury and Talus discussing
the wife's death uh we can discuss that
I did
I did talk about it in my breakdown
yesterday
um
yeah is that age
it is AJ hello AJ
hello
hello did Iron Man die
yeah yeah Iron Man Died In Avengers
endgame yes yes
is that sad yeah I know I haven't seen
the episode yet but I'm very excited
okay well we are we are talking about
all the spoilers so get out of here
actively
give it to me
uh
we're we're actually about to wrap up
the stream
um so jump in the other Discord we'll
talk to you after okay so goodbye
um relax just so we can have the better
screen back yeah I was like oh you
actually did it
um
that scene
I I love to and I I think I did this
more in my breakdown for this series
this this episode I think that's why
it's like 30 something minutes it's like
I I so a lot of people don't know this I
went to graduate I almost texted you too
I was almost like Chris uh I'm just
gonna head to that point
it's over 30 minutes long I just kept
talking I got the email and I was like
yeah
um graduate school
oh I went I was in I went to graduate
school for psychology
um
so I really like diving into like
emotions so when Fury reunites with
Talos and by the way hasn't he always
been called Talos why are they calling
him Talos now that's I had the same
thing
he was definitely Tallow and even the
one guy was his name was a scroll right
and even the one guy said Your name's
not Keller or Kellen whatever the fake
name was it is I'm like he said Tyler's
right there anyways I digress
um you know when they greet each other
by touching their heads like it's very
intimate I really like that but clearly
his wife Soren
um love Fury he says that and I think
that also hits him really really hard
too because it's kind of like that's
Nick Fury's fault
and he and at first when he said like
I'm sorry I thought he was saying I'm
I'm sorry to him because he didn't find
him like a new planet yet but no he was
saying I'm sorry for your wife and and
and Taylor's
says so I love so much response but then
even after I was like but let's talk
about you for a minute he's like tell me
about that we know Taylor's loved his
wife but we got stuff to do like yeah
super sad but you know well fear has
been gone for such a long time I think
Talus Talos whatever has had a uh had
some time
to to cope with that although since Gaia
didn't know I I'm assuming it's pretty
pretty fresh actually what did AJ say
and stuff again yeah and what I gathered
about the series after the first episode
it's all down oh no oh AJ oh Deputy 10
24. wow
too soon it's it's not even been 24
hours has it even been 12 hours yeah
okay yeah not even 24 hours all downhill
wait I have to I have to oh
oh I can't do it you can't do it I don't
care uh dang it again just not easily
have to do yeah and then downhill
uh oh there you go
um
everyone everyone else uh
did did did Gaia essentially lie to
Talos about the final scene
no I so here's this is what the final
thing I'll say before we wrap it up here
I appreciate everybody joining us today
it's been a while since we've done the
lives I love it
um my setup was kind of messy like the
sun's still shining yeah right my setup
was kind of messy today so I'm looking
at the chat on my phone so I apologize
if I you know haven't said hi to
everybody and stuff like that I'll get
it better next time but
I don't think
graphic trust Gaia at all I actually
think he's using her uh to to relay
information
as a trap I think he knows like this is
talus's daughter
and you know Taos is gonna you know meet
with her and try to get her back
especially after he it sounds like maybe
not him personally but definitely his
plans killed her mother
he he's smart he's a smart villain he's
definitely going to be like yeah she's
going to go back but I'm going to try to
keep her close to me and tell her things
and she's going to in turn tell them
which is going to just be a trap so I
think that ending was a trap by grab it
and they even say it like
these are decoys they're not real
he used Gaia I don't think Gaia did that
I think Gaia is legitimately
trying to be on the side of her father I
think she's one of the same time
she could have done it yeah but I I
actually really don't think so I I think
I think she's caught in the middle but
the death of her mom has made her sway
back to kind of the side of her dad and
I think I think ravic is using her and I
think it was a trap and she was a pawn
and setting up that trap for gravic I
also love like I just want to talk about
how
you know like the bad guy monologue that
always gets them killed and like foils
their plans when they try to talk to the
hero I love it graphic just turned and
was like
Boop like not even like holding it up
for like a little bit he literally was
just like
Boop boom thousands definitely Man of
Action yeah
it's so good to see because it's so
practical right a lot of refreshing a
lot of refreshing things for the MCU and
as a whole in in just that first episode
yeah yeah
yeah and I you know in my
spoiler free review which is not this
spoilers all the spoilers
um
why am I streaming at 720p am I no I
don't know
it was all the normal settings it
clicked dream and that's what happened
there's all the normal settings that I I
used to have
guys are lucky he turned his camera on
that's true I had a problem turning my
camera on next time we'll try to be
better sorry thanks proud pleb for
calling me out but yeah no I I like uh I
like a serious villain who is just like
literally just about confident killing
like I'm a villain I'm gonna do what I
want like
it's like I always think of like Austin
Powers like the third one with Seth
Green I think yeah Seth Green
um and he's you know Dr Evil's like all
right close the door leave him in the in
the pit with you know the sharks with
the laser beams and he's like what
you're not gonna kill him right now he's
like Scott don't and he's like no I got
a gun in my room but we could do it
together we'll kill him Bam Bam and it's
like they're obviously making fun uh you
know it's parody of the Spy Thrillers
where the villains are like you know oh
I'm gonna leave now and what You Know
You're Gonna slowly like fall into acid
by this rail but of course they always
get away this is just kind of like nope
he is not playing around
spoilers coming up again uh click away
if you don't want to be spoiled for
episode one you know he blows he blows
up to Town Square thousands of people
die and then just kills Hill like and
and I love I've put in my thumbnail
today I love his smile when he looks at
Fury
as Fury when he shot her you know just
this big old grin villainous grin on his
face and it's just like
I didn't kill you right yeah she's like
I didn't kill you I killed someone you
care about most in the world and I'm not
gonna kill you now
but hey this is what I can do and I'm
not playing around and I think it was
just like and that's why I think as sad
as it is
Hill should be dead
because I don't want you to take away
from that one take away from the villain
how serious he is and and two take away
from something that could probably Drive
Fury to be the best of the best
Deputy you know I have one simple
request and that is to have sharks with
freaking laser beams attached to their
freaking heads and if you guys haven't
seen us the Austin power Trilogy y'all
need to because it's hilarious might be
before somebody else time
Chris
um but yeah no I think that was a
good start
I think it was a great start I um
and I honestly don't know what's coming
up beyond episode two which I've seen
but beyond that I don't I don't know
what we're like in for like
yeah I'm pretty excited about that too
yeah
yeah I
you know people I don't know which
episode's better one or two I liked them
both but I have
somebody asked a question in the chat a
bit ago I'm sorry I don't remember who
but I think
the story will get wrapped up here but I
think the scroll being in the MCU were
going to have an everlasting presence
just because
I can't I mean sure there's something
what
I was gonna say surely they've hinted at
it enough already like the the way the
water settles is like coexistence right
right well basically in the next episode
there's kind of some dialogue
that kind of make you go and they even
make Fury go like holy crap like you get
a you get a TR basically you get a
glimpse of how big of a threat the
scroll actually are and I don't know how
the whole story is going to end by
episode six but I would assume that
there are just gonna be scroll in the
MCU forever
right like they might wrap up the story
in this series and revisit it seven
years later right who who knows
um and maybe it'll be like
maybe it'll be like at the end just a
little teaser it's like you think all
the bad scroll are dead or something
like that but then you find you know
little T's that one of them got away and
is disguised as like
I don't know the president of
wherever different countries something
like that it is who knows but I I've I
like this a lot because I'm a big spy
Espionage fan and I don't care if this
has
you know little action and I I think it
was I think it's going to be pretty dang
good I do I think it is definitely one
of the better things to come from Marvel
hey thanks Bucky Barnes Atlanta Joe we
appreciate Warren and let's get this a
weekly thing if you've got time we'll
fool if yeah no this is going to be or
try to do a weekly thing uh I'll finish
by saying we're doing the the chat at
this time because it's I I can't
continue every time there's a new Disney
Plus show to do a watch party I just I
obviously plan on doing this as long as
I can rest of my life and if I have to
go live at 3am
4 a.m for Chris you know every single
time
and do a full breakdown after
and go to bed at 7 A.M each morning
which will you know just throws off my
schedule so much
um and just really messes with my mental
strength like my mental health it's hard
to recover from those days so I think
we're just gonna do a discussion
the next day after now you know
um I think and I asked it almost anyway
because I had time to ingest it a little
bit right exactly and more people get
time to watch it at this point in time
and um
that that is something something people
have said like oh you know I I can't
join the watch parties when it's that
late at night which obviously yeah I get
it it's hard for us to do Tuesday right
on like a Tuesday night it's like when
you know people go to work they're like
saying stuff like that so I think this
is uh probably around like four or five
six
um P.M
mountain time that's the time zone I'm
in mountain time uh uh the following or
the day of the show that way people get
enough time to watch it I think that's
what we're gonna that's what we're gonna
do yeah yeah
did The Avengers ever find out that
Colson returned
um
yeah there was a there was an episode of
Agents of Shield where uh Captain
America was in it
so I'm assuming he told them
uh I it would be it is weird that he
never popped up again in the MCU ever
right it is kind of weird but um yeah uh
yes Proxima Century I I have a video
planned on that but I wanted to go live
today to uh to talk about this so yeah
nice Andrew I'm alert I am
a big fan of the mountains out here I
live kind of at the base of a mountain
so it's pretty cool but hey all right
everybody thank you all for joining uh
Chris is also live on Twitch right now
Chris if you want to uh throw that in
the chat you guys want to follow him he
goes live and talks about Marvel DC
movies in general um he he does that
once a week as well uh go ahead a couple
times a week right now a couple times a
week right now you can follow him as
well uh if you're a fan of Marvel on the
channel
be sure to subscribe that's all we talk
about here Marvel in DC
um and yeah I appreciate everybody we're
gonna do this again next week today's
Wednesday
it's Wednesday it's Wednesday this is
what this is what the shows this is why
we're doing this during the day now
because they I should have seen it when
we lived together and we did these and
like we go get McDonald's at 7am after
we were done and just like burgers yeah
like uh be crazy but um
but yeah um
I I love the show so far I really do it
wasn't like this isn't anything like I
felt with She-Hulk or any of the other
recent shows that we've gotten lately
I'm actually I'm pretty invested in this
because I genuinely one don't know
what's gonna happen and two want to know
what's gonna happen uh makes it exciting
it does you don't know who's a scroll
all like if someone dies or they're
really dead like there's a lot of
mystery in this and I'm really excited
and looking forward to seeing how it
turns out so
next Wednesday I've tried to think again
next Wednesday we'll be back I'll try to
put out like a community post
um or like uh what do they call like
premieres or like
how you can set the basically in advance
that's a good idea yeah yeah so I'll try
to put that out ahead so everybody knows
what time it's going to be but yeah
around four or five six pm mountain time
um that way people can get off work or
they can watch and listen on the way
home or something like that and
everybody has enough time to digest the
episode so we can have a good spoiler
talk so again you guys can follow Chris
on Twitch and um
oh thank you Gabriel I'll look into that
next time but yeah you guys Follow Chris
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel we'll be putting out some more
videos this week of course uh try to do
some secret Invasion ones with some
theories that we have and we'll catch
you guys next Wednesday I think again
all right thanks everybody